bonjour à tous je vous propose ce matin
de suivre une proposition de résolution
sur la simplification des normes alors
ce texte présenté par le groupe
centriste la semaine dernière a été
adopté il vise à limiter à simplifier
les normes pour faciliter la vie des
collectivités en particulier en matière
d'urbanisme mais de construction la
résolution propose notamment de
clarifier les relations entre les
collectivités et certains de leur de
leurs interlocuteurs comme les
commissions de sécurité ou les agences
régionales de santé elle veut aussi
alléger les formalités pesants sur les
actes et les documents d'urbanisme grâce
à un formulaire de déclaration préalable
pour certains types de travaux le
gouvernement étudiera attentivement
chacune de vos propositions a d'ailleurs
assuré le secrétaire d'État à la réforme
territorial André Vallini voilà donc
tout de suite je vous propose de suivre
cette séance l'ordre du jour appelle
l'examen de la proposition de résolution
tendant à limiter le poids de la
réglementation applicable aux
collectivités territoriales pardon et à
simplifier certaines normes
réglementaires relatives à l'urbanisme
et à la construction présenté en
application de l'article 341 de la
Constitution par Monsieur Jean-Marie
bouquel et plusieurs de ses collègues
dans la discussion générale la parole
est à Monsieur Jean-Marie bouquel auteur
de la proposition deux résolutions vous
avez la parole mon cher collègue pour 10
minutes merci beaucoup monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues voilà les les jours se se
suivent et se ressemblent du moins en ce
qui nous concerne autour de cette
problématique des normes nous avons en
effet adopté hier une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle qui devrait notamment
et notablement
contribuer le jour où elle sera mise en
œuvre à corriger à la source la
propension de notre culture politique et
juridique à accumulé dans la loi et dans
la réglementation des prescriptions
redondantes des exigences
disproportionnées des procédures
inextricables chaque élu local ne cesse
d'expérimenter tout au long de ces
mandats à quel point ce phénomène
entrave l'action au-delà de ce que
requiert la sécurité des procédures et
renchérri les coûts au-delà de ce que
permet la contraction des ressources
publiques surtout en ce temps en C temps
de rigueur de réduction des dotations il
fallait donc viser la source de
l'inflation normative qui est bien
souvent législative et c'est pourquoi
nous avons souhaité inscrire dans la
Constitution elle-même le principe de la
compensation par l'état des charges
supplémentaires créées par les normes
nouvelles il n'y a pas de moyen plus
efficace de créer le changement dans
notre façon de légiférer et de
réglementer et de se rapprocher de la
réalité européenne qui nous entoure et
qui finalement ne fonctionne pas si mal
bien au contraire mais nous avons
souhaité parallèlement à cette
initiative constitutionnelle faire
progresser la sobriété normative en
rappelant un principe simple pour une
règle pour une norme réglementaire créée
une norme supprimée ou allégée c'est le
premier objet de notre proposition de
résolution des initiatives ont déjà été
pris en ce sens avec l'inscription de ce
principe dans la circulaire du 17
juillet 2013 relative à la mise en œuvre
du gel de la
réglementation cependant le secrétaire
d'État chargé de la réforme de l'État et
de la simplification a indiqué lui-même
en réponse à une question orale que ce
texte n'était qu'un premier pas donner à
l'objectif de simplification la priorité
qu'il mérite suppose en effet une
profonde évolution de la culture
administrative une circulaire si utile
soit-elle ne peut y suffire dans la
durée c'est la raison pour laquelle
notre proposition de résolution suggère
dans sa première partie de rehausser
dans la hiérarchie des normes le
principe selon lequel l'ajout d'une
norme doit être compensé par la
suppression ou l'allègement d'une autre
dans le casadre de la réglementation
applicable aux collectivités
territoriales c'est une façon
pragmatique de réguler les flux de
normes nouvelles tout en s'attaquant par
la bande au stock existant car le
problème du stock est crucial en effet
alors que les ressources des
collectivités subissent de la part de
l'état des pressions une pression
massive les coûtes économiques
techniques et administratives de
l'empilement matif existant sont devenus
insupportables c'est pourquoi nous
devons engager une action systématique
de réduction de ces stocks les élus
locaux nous le demande de manière
insistante et réitérée et ils ont raison
mais par quoi commencer notre délégation
a posé la question aux élus en les
interrogeant sur leurs priorités à
l'occasion du congrès des mares en 2014
le niveau de participation à notre
consultation remémy poter le rappelé
encore hier a été significatif lors de
sa fermeture en février 2015 près de 42
200 réponses avaient été transmises à la
délégation les résultats ont été
parlants 64 % presque des réponses ont
mentionné l'urbanisme et le droit des
sols comme secteur prioritaire pour la
simplification c'est pourquoi notre
délégation a voulu consacrer ses
premiers travaux de simplification du
stock de normes aux dispositions
régissant l'urbanisme sous l'impulsion
de remémy pore notre premier
vice-président délégué nous sommes dans
un premier temps intéressés à la
réglementation la deuxème partie de la
proposition de résolution dont nous
débattons aujourd'hui est
l'aboutissement de cette démarche elle
identifie plus d'une dizaine de pistes
de simplification concrète qui nous
semble à même de montrer que le
processus de simplification s'enclenche
qu'il s'intensifie que la demande
exprimée par les élus locaux ne reste
pas sans réponse que le Sénat totalement
inscrit dans sa mission de représentant
des collectivités territoriales est à la
manœuvre certaines de ces pistes sont
connues de tous notre collègue Éric
d'ligliger les a présenté dans son
rapport de 2011 il le rappelait encore
ère sur la simplification des normes
applicables aux collectivités
territoriales 5 ans après elles sont
toujours d'actualité certaines autres
pistes ont fait l'objet de l'annonce de
la part du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre les plus récentes remontent au
14 septembre dernier souhaitons en ce
qui les concernes que le Sénat serve
d'Aiguillon pour que ces annonces se
concrétisent pleinement et rapidement je
disant cela je ne mets d'ailleurs pas en
doute la la la détermination du
gouvernement que ce soit vous-même que
ce soit monsieur Mandon avec qui nous
avons parlé de progresser sur ce sujet
mais vous savez bien que entre le
vouloir et y aller vraiment il est bon
que hein ce ce dialogue ce ce rôle qui
est le nôtre fonctionne aussi pleinement
et c'est aussi l'esprit un peu de cette
résolution qui n'a naturellement aucune
valeur contraignante mais qui est un un
signal fort dans la mesure où bien sûr
elle serait adopté ce que j'espère je
distinguerai quatre catégories de de
propositions tout d'abord trois
dispositions de la disposition de la
proposition de résolution appelle le
gouvern à clarifier au moyen
d'instruments de droit souple des
chartes ou des référentiels élaborés en
concertation avec les élus locaux un peu
l'esprit dans lequel vous avez travaillé
vous le disiez hier en écoutant des élus
locaux des DGS et cetera donc disais-je
clarifier les relations entre les
collectivité et certains de leurs
interlocuteurs les commissions de
sécurité les officiers préventionnistes
les architectes des bâtiments de France
les agences régionales de santé quatre
dispositions de la proposition de
résolution incite le gouvernement à
simplifier les règles de de construction
et de gestion des établissements
recevant du public sujet sensible en
portant à la connaissance des préfets et
des élus locaux les dérogations aux
règles d'accessibilité existant dans une
circulaire en ajustant la périodicité de
certains contrôles à commencé par ce
relatif aux installations électriques en
élargissant la possibilité
d'installation de classes démontables
dans les établissements scolaires
faisant l'objet de travaux et en
assouplissant les normes parasismiques
dans les zones et pour les bâtiments
présentant un très faible enjeu au
regard du risque sismique quatre autres
dispositions de la proposition de
résolution invite le gouvernement à
alléger les formalités pesant sur les
actes et des documents d'urbanisme grâce
à la simplification d'un formulaire de
déclaration préalable le SERFA
13404 pour certains types d'aménagement
de construction et de travaux à
l'établissement également de la liste
précise des actes d'urbanisme de faible
importance pouvant être exclus du
contrôle de légalité à la limitation à
un mois de la majoration éventuelle des
instruction de droits commun des
déclarations préalables des permis de
construire et des permis d'aménager et à
la simplification des obligations
réglementaires pesant sur les plans
locaux d'urbanisme en particulier les
études exigées dans les zones humides
qui n'a pas été confronté hein sur son
territoire à des conflits à des
interrogations des
incertitudes sur ce sujet sensible je
peux comme beaucoup d'autres ici en
témoigner les deux dernières
dispositions de la proposition de
résolution ont très à des équipements et
des aménagements posant des difficultés
spécifiques dans nos territoires elles
tendent d'une part à accompagner les
communes dans la mise en conformité de
leurs équipements d'assaainissement
collectif avec la réglementation
européenne et d'autre part à permettre
le regroupement des différents dossiers
préalable à la création d'une zone
d'aménagement concertée en un seul cet
ensemble pourrait paraître un peu
technique et passablement fragmentaire
mais tous ceux parmi vous et celles
parmi vous là qui qui à un titre ou un
autre des élus locaux comprennent
parfaitement de quoi je parle pour avoir
été d'une manière ou d'une autre et à un
moment ou un autre sollicité sur ces
questions donc au fond c'est peut-être
technique mais c'est concret et c'est
c'est basé sur un sur un vécu et souvent
sur un mal vécu de cette euh énumération
euh c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'invite le Sénat à adopter la présente
proposition de loi non non pas j'invite
nous invitons parce que ce travail cette
proposition est le fruit d'un travail
collectif euh cher euh réy poinfo je
vous citais à plusieurs reprises
évoquant le rôle du groupe de travail
que que vous animez au sein de la
délégation et auquel je veux vraiment
rendre hommage parce que c'est un
travail de titan vous le faites dans un
bon esprit avec Alain Lambert hein qui a
été longtemps sur nos bancs et y compris
dans cette délégation au niveau du
Conseil des nommes qu'il préside
aujourd'hui il faut savoir aussi et on
l'a vu hier que nous travaillons
également en bonne intelligence avec les
différentes commission permanente nous
hein nous ne voulons pas supplanter ni
ni remettre en question bien au
contraire leur rôle nous sommes dans la
transversalité je pense particulièrement
à la commission des lois avec laquelle
nous avons sur ces questions qui
relèvent de sa compétence un très bon
dialogue mais également avec les autres
commissions on le verra d'ailleurs dans
la suite de nos travaux de la délégation
dès cette semaines donc nous sommes je
dirais nombreux au sein de la délégation
et même au-delà et certainement sur tous
les bancs à souhaité que cette
proposition soit adoptée les élus locaux
il verront un signe de l'attention que
nous portons à leur problè problèm
concret le président Larcher d'ailleurs
il est personnellement sensible et
également donneré une forte impulsion à
nos travaux notre délégation y verra
également un encouragement à poursuivre
sa tâche austère et le gouvernement il
verra j'en suis sûr une incitation à
mener à bonne fin les travaux qu'il a
entrepris de son côté car le
gouvernement quel qu'il soit et à toute
époque est aussi confronté à un certain
nombre de freins et de pesanteurs et je
pense que à travers cette résolution
nous nous aidons sa sa bonne volonté
sincère d'avancer sur cette question qui
nous tient très à cœur merci merci mon
chers collègu dans la suite de la
discussion générale la parole est à
Monsieur Jean-Pierre
bino vous avez la parole mon cher
collègue
président monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre chers collègues nous
abordons aujourd'hui un sujet cela a été
dit au sein de notre hémicycle et dans
les réflexions des pouvoirs publics qui
est récurrent ainsi en 1991 le Conseil
d'État faisait déjà part de ses
inquiétudes concernant la complexité du
droit caractérisé par la prolifération
désordonnée des textes l'instabilité
croissante des règles et la dégradation
manifeste de la norme en 2011 une
mission d'information cel a été dit sur
cette question a été conduite par les
par le Sénat sous les l'égide de la
délégation aux collectivités
territoriales et porté par notre
collègue ERC doliget ce rapport a abouti
au dépôt d'une proposition de loi
toujours en cours de navette et que
l'examen de cette proposition de
résolution remet d'une certaine façon au
goût du jour de fait le sujet est
important en particulier pour les les
élus locaux aujourd'hui ce sont plus de
400000 normes qui sont
applicables cette situation pose de
vraies question lié notamment à
l'insécurité juridique pour les
collectivités trop de normes tue l'idée
même de la norme et rend impossible
l'idée que la loi soit connue et
intelligible par tous c'est donc aussi
un problème démocratique mais il faut
aller plus loin et remettre en cause non
seulement le volume mais tout autant les
modes d'élaboration de la norme et de la
loi les efforts à produire en matière de
démocratie sont immenses et qu'en ce
domaine aussi les collectivités et
notamment les communes ont fait preuve
d'un esprit d'initiative et d'innovation
remarquable à d'autres endroits et
notamment dans le cadre de l'élaboration
de la loi trop souvent nous nous
trouvons enfermés dans des débats
d'experts or de la vivacité de notre
démocratie dépend aussi la qualité des
normes et des lois pour autant il faut
être clair cette volonté de diminuer les
normes et donc les contraintes sur les
collectivités ne doit pas conduire à
réduire la qualité et la sécurité de
l'offre auprès de nos
concitoyens limiter les normes ne doit
pas constituer non plus une forme de
déréglementation des secteurs que sont
l'urbanisme le logement et
l'environnement dans lesquels les
objectifs en matière d'accessibilité de
sécurité de normes sanitaires et de
protection de l'environnement seraient
relégué comme des questions annexes ou
trop complexes une telle posture est
dangereuse par ailleurs derrière le
rejet des normes par les élus se cache
pour beaucoup des difficultés plus
réelles pour mettre en œuvre ces
dernière faute d'accompagnement
technique par les administrations et de
soutien financier par l'État nous
regrettons d'ailleurs en matière
d'urbanisme la quasi suppression de
l'assistance technique de l'État la
tesat tout comme la baisse des dotations
qui obèent les capacités d'intervention
des collectivités et leurs moyens
humains pour garantir le respect ces
normes gardons ce fait à l'esprit
l'édiction de règles répond le plus
souvent à un besoin in essentiel de
sécurité technique et juridique au-delà
de ces considérations l'utilité des
normes c'est aussi l'argument libéral
qui est érigé ainsi dans la discussion
sur la proposition de loi de notre
collègue Éric Doliger rappelait
l'essentiel n'oublions pas que la
compétitivité se mesure sur les marchés
internationaux celui qui ne maîtrise pas
ses charges et contraintes perd de la
compétitivité chaque norme supérieure à
celle de nos concurrents nous pénalise
fin de citation nous ne sommes donc pas
seulement et apparemment dans une
volonté de sécuriser les collectivités
mais bien aussi de libéraliser les
secteurs économiques qui ne le seraient
pas encore en abaissant les normes
qu'ell soi urbanistique environnementale
de sécurité ou encore sociale ce
discours
d'ultralibéralisme débridé conduit à des
catastrophes humaines sociales et
environnement nous le savons les
sénateurs et sénatrices du groupe CRC
condamnent cette orientation politique
du mo-s 10 ans nous pouvons nous avancer
deux propositions pour éviter l'écueil
de loi uti mais inapplicable faute de
moyens ne faudrait-il pas prévoir de
manière systématique un volet fixant les
règles financières de leur mise en œuvre
deuxièmement ne pourrait-on pas
encourager plus encore le dialogue avec
les autorités devant délivrer des avis
que sont notamment les architectes des
bâtiments de France ou les agences
régionales de santé pour éviter un
recours systématique à la justice
administrative par ailleurs surchargé et
qui allonge les délais s'agissant des
propositions formulées dans cette
proposition de
résolution il faut bien reconnaître que
nous ne les partageons pas notamment sur
le principe pour une norme créée une
norme supprimé nous considérons que
cette affirmation est purement
démagogique ce qui doit doit prévaloir
pour définir le droit positif c'est non
sa masse globale mais bien de savoir si
ces normes sont justes et utiles toute
idée mécanique est donc à bannir quand à
savoir si un décret a plus de force
qu'une circulaire franchement ce débat
sur la hiérarchie des normes
réglementaires est bien en desessà des
enjeux que vous posez cette proposition
de résolution semble être une curieuse
collection de propositions issues de
divers rapports et propositions de àorté
et contenu extrêmement variaable allant
de la santé à l'environnement en passant
par la réglementation de
l'assaainissement la plupart de ces
mesures relèvent d'ailleurs purement du
pouvoir réglementaire ou même du bon
sens allant même jusqu'à évoquer la
question de formulaire
administratif la création de chares
nationale pour fixer le niveau
d'exigence des commissions de sécurité
ou sur le niveau d'exigence des
architectes des bâtiments de France
relève là encore uniquement de bonnes
pratiques le fil conducteur de ces
propositions c'est au fond l'idée que
l'administration par nature serait
arbitraire et même dangereuse alors
qu'elle protège aussi les administrés et
notre
environnement d'autres préconisations
nous semblent tout autant problématiques
notamment en matière d'urbanisme avec
cette volonté tenace de déréglementer le
droit du sol il est il en est est ainsi
de la proposition qui souhaite voir
établi une liste des actes d'urbanisme
de faible importance pouvant être exclus
du contrôle de légalité ou alors
carrément de limiter la réglementation
applicable au plans locaux d'urbanisme
pour ces raisons nous ne voterons pas ce
texte nous demandons pour notre part en
priorité et pour soulager les
collectivités et derrière les questions
des normes c'est cela d'ailleurs le vrai
sujet au gouvernement de cesser ces
coupes budgétaires de remettre les les
fonctionnaires dans les préfectures et
les services déconcentrés pour que les
collectivités puissent mener les
politiques pour lesquelles elles ont été
élu merci merci mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Joël
labéésident merci
beaucoup
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le chantier
de simplification est en cours depuis le
mois de mars 2013 suite à l'annonce par
le Président de la République de son
choc de
simplification je ne suis pas
nécessairement convaincu par les
thérapies de choc de manière générale je
préfère les évolutions aux
révolutions les petits matins et oui les
petits matins au grand soir et les
transitions concertées plutôt que les
bouleversements soudains et imposés ça
nous arrive peut-être avec l'âge
heureusement dans cette œuvre de
simplification il y a eu de la
concertation et nous avons examiné dans
cet hémicycle de nombreux textes de
simplification ces ces deux dernières
années et la plupart d'entre eux ont
fait l'objet d'une concertation
préalable avec les acteurs économiques
et industriels et cela est ind pensable
c'est aujourd'hui le travail de notre
délégation aux collectivités
territoriales qui est en discussion il
ne s'agit pas là d'un travail partisan
et cela par les temps qui court est
particulièrement appréciable en tant
qu'ancien maire je comprends très bien
la détresse de certains élus locaux face
aux réglementations extrêmement
complexes notamment en matière
d'urbanisme cette résolution vient
répondre en partie à cette détresse et
je souscris à cet
objectif
toutefois en tant
qu'écologiste nous resterons vigilants
il ne faut pas confondre simplification
et
déréglementations certaines normes sont
utiles si elles sont arrivées là ce
n'est pas non plus par hasard parce
qu'il y a eu des excès elle mérite
parfois d'être assouplie mais il ne faut
pas que cela vienne écorner leur
utilité il serait nécessaire de faire un
premier bilan de l'activité du Conseil
national d'évaluation des normes que
nous avons réformé à l'initiative de
notre assemblée à travers une
proposition de loi commune de deux
piliers de notre assemblée Jacqueline
gourau et Jean-Pierre Sueur dont je veux
saluer ici le travail et la
détermination dans un certain état
d'esprit la la loi du 17 octobre 2013 a
permis de
consacrer à l'initiative d'un amendement
de notre ancienne collègue Hélène
lipiette je l'ai croisé tout à l'heure
dans les couloirs je sais pas si est par
là mais je voudrais la saluer donc la
proposition du Président de la
République de voir pour chaque norme
nouvelle applicable aux collectivités
territoriales une norme devenue inutile
ou obsolète abrogé l'avis rendu par le
Conseil national sur des dispositions
réglementaires en vigueur peut proposer
des modalités de simplification de ses
dispositions et l'abrogation de normes
devenu obsolète c'est donc aujourd'hui
avec une certaine
satisfaction que je peux
oser soutenir ce
texte qui a pour objectif de remcer de
renforcer ce principe ce texte prend des
précaution bienvenue lorsqu'il évoque
dans son alinéa 6 que les normes
nouvelles ne doivent entraîner une
simplification ou une suppression
uniquement dans le cas où ces normes
constituent une contrainte ou une charge
pour les
collectivités la proposition d'élaborer
une charte nationale harmonisant les
niveaux d'exigen des commissions de
sécurité et des offices
préventionnistes les architectes les
architectes des bâtiments de France est
selon moi selon nous intéressante elle
pourra va permettre une application plus
lisible des différentes normes sur
l'ensemble du territoire national et
cela d'une façon objective et non plus
subjective en en fonction du regard de
du fonctionnaire ou du groupe qui veille
les écologistes seront vigilants si le
gouvernement traduit effectivement notre
résolution présente en acte
réglementaire ainsi concernant
l'assaainissement
collectif si je comprends parfaitement
l'objectif poursuivi je m'inquiète d'une
application qui pourrait être l'aciste
de la délivrance de permis de construire
sur la fois de simple délai déclaratif
de mise en conformité il va falloir être
très ferme là-dessus de la même manière
j'aimerais bien connaître votre
définition des actes de faible
importance qui seraient exclus du
contrôle de la l'égalité en matière
d'urbanisme aussi ne faut-il pas
renforcer les effectif chargé du
contrôle puisque puisqu'il semble que
que le contrôle effectif des actes soit
insuffisant plutôt que de sortir du
cadre du contrôle un grand nombre
d'actes administratifs au risque qu'il
ne respecte pas la loi et cela malgré
leur relative leur toute relative
moindre importance le respect de la loi
i ne peut pas être à géométrie variable
même si dans les faits c'est
malheureusement trop souvent le cas et
nous ne pouvons nous accommoder ces
réserves posées au regard de l'esprit de
véritable simplification de ce texte
esprit attendu au nom de mon groupe je
voterai favorablement cette
proposition un complément puisqu'il m'en
reste 15 secondes pour vous dire que qu'
un des futurs axes de travail pourrait
être le droit à l'expérimentation
encadrée en terme d'urbanisme j'ai eu
l'occasion de visiter un endroit habité
par l'ensemble des habitats alternatives
que ce soit la yourt la cabane l'habitat
en paill et terre cela sans
autorisation mais par contre d'une façon
extrêmement respectueuse de l'esprit de
la cop21 je réclame là-dessus sur ce
genre de chos le droit à
l'expérimentation mais je pense enfin il
sera nécessaire que l'on en je vous
remercie merci mon cher
collègue la parole est au président
Jacques
mard monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
cette proposition de
résolution vient au bon moment et bien
sûr nous la voterons parce que pour nous
elle va dans le bon
sens nous sommes un pays qui a une
administration particulièrement
compétente et efficace tellement
compétente et efficace que d'ailleurs si
on pouvait l'exporter et y trouver
des bénéfices au niveau de notre balance
commerciale ce serait parfait
elle est tellement compétente
d'ailleurs que elle a pris le pouvoir
très souvent et que les plus hauts
responsables de ce pays sont le plus
souvent issus des grands corps de
l'État cela étant dit nous qui sommes
pour la plupart d'entre nous des élus
locaux tant qu'on nous en laisse encore
le droit c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que
nous avons un avis assez pertinent à
donner en matière d'urbanisme en matière
d'assaainissement parce que dans nos
collectivités nous savons ce que
c'est demain ce sera certainement
différent
et et mes chers
collègues cette administration est
tellement compétente qu'elle ne peut pas
s'empêcher de travailler nous devrions
nous en réjouir et nous le faisons
souvent et dans des domaines qui nous
tiennent particulièrement à à cœur et
même si ça ne concerne que peu
l'urbanisme et certains dossier abordé
par cette excellente résolution je vous
invite vivement à faire
lecture de la circulaire du 22 décembre
2015 chef-dœuvre de notre
administration
concernant l'application de la loi
notre vous y verrez d'ailleurs que pour
une
circulaire moi j'ai fait un peu de droit
dans ma vie dans à l'université comme
étudiant comme enseignant au barreau
pendant quelques décennies et je je
pensais que les circulaires n'avaient
d'impact que sur les services de l'État
mais à partir du moment où dans les
circulaires nous continuons à ce que
l'on nous explique quels sont les les
transferts de compétences ou les
évolutions acceptables ou pas
il faut tous que vous lisiez cette
excellente circulaire parce que elle
prolonge dans le même esprit la loi nôre
vous y verrez par exemple qu'en matière
de liaison aérienne et
bien le département ne peut plus
intervenir sauf s'il y a un caractère
touristique indiscutablement
prépondérant et que la région peut
organiser c'est-à-dire que on vous dit
ce que vous avez le droit de faire ou
pas dans une circulaire et et très
clairement on va essayer par le contrôle
de l'égalité de l'imposer à nos
collectivités si c'est ça l'évolution
positive qui nous est annoncée par
l'exécutif en matière de réglementation
et de normes monsieur le ministre je
considère qu'on peut faire beaucoup
mieux et qu'en tout cas ça fait encore
un faussé entre les déclarations
publique et
l'action
je je pourrais je pourrais m'arrêter là
mais je vais faire totalement
abstraction du document qu'on m'avait
excellemment préparé pour vous dire la
suite
lorsque nous avons le tort les uns et
les autres de confondre un peu trop
régle le problème de la réglementation
et le problème des
normes c'est c'est pas tout à fait la
même
chose la
réglementation de la loi il en faut mais
comme nous le disons souvent moins on a
de texte et c'est à un excellent juriste
que je m'adresse monsieur le ministre
moins on a de texte plus on les applique
et plus on en fabrique moins on les
applique soit parce que même
l'administration ne les connaît plus
soit parce que quand on fait on vote des
lois on va pas regarder ce qui existait
avant et et nous vivons dans un système
qui est devenu malheureusement un
système d'insécurité
juridique mais ce qui nous pose problème
pour avancer dans ce pays nous avons
tous dans nos collectivités dans nos
communes dans nos intercommunalités dans
nos départements dans nos régions la
volonté de développer les projets je
crois que ce qui ce qui monsieur le
ministre je je ne doute pas d'ailleurs
que vous pensiez la même
chose ce qui rendrait service à cette
nation c'est comprenne sur des exemples
concrets c'est-à-dire la construction
d'un dossier de développement par des
collectivités tout le mécanisme
indispensable administratif qui nous est
imposé pour arriver au but qui nous
prend souvent des années avec la
multiplication de
commissions nous
avons ENF nous voulons tous simplifier
les choses vous vous avez fait des
efforts même si nous ne les avons pas
nous ne sommes pas d'accord sur les
conclusions sur la réforme territoriale
Vous il faut il faut simplifier les
choses simplifier les choses ça serait
déjà supprimer toute une série d'agences
de structures intermédiaires qui font
perdre du temps de l'argent et des
commissions administratives dans les
préfectures qui nous posent des
problèmes insurmontables chaque année
chaque année comme président
d'agglomération on me demande le nom
d'un élu pour aller siéger à la
Commission souris je rassure monsieur
l'abbé je suis pour la protection des
chauvve-souris mais quand je vois que
dans un département comme le mien il y a
une quarantaine d'élus et de
fonctionnaires qui se réunissent sur le
devenir et la protection des
chauves-souris je pense que un
fonctionnaire suffirait bon c'est un
exemple caricatural mais je crois que
là-dessus nous pouvons tous être
d'accord donc j'en conclus là-dessus
bravo à cette résolution nous la
voterons il faut mais il faut faire
beaucoup plus et Monsieur le Ministre
arrêz de faire faire des circulaires qui
finalement ont un caractère impératif à
ceux qui n'en sont pas les destinataires
merci mon cher collègue la parole est à
Monsieur remémi
pointerau bien monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
nous continuons cette semaine consacrée
à la simplification des normes et j'en
suis très heureux et tout comme le
président Jean-Marie Boquel je me
réjouis que le Sénat a adopté hier la
proposition de loi constitutionnelle que
j'ai présenté et c'est je le crois un
texte bien sûr
important qui fixe à l'état l'obligation
de compenser aux collectivités
territorial le coût induit par toute
norme qui les dictent à leur égard il
s'agit d'une claire affirmation du
principe prescripteur payeur cette règle
semble indispensable pour
responsabiliser l'État central et est la
condition pour
handiguer la profusion de normes et de
dépenses et rétablir une relation de
confiance entre l'échelon local et
national et favoriser ainsi un
changement de culture normative mais la
simplification normative doit être
appréhendée par les de bouts d'abord en
amont par l'inscription dans la
Constitution d'un cadre robuste contre
le Zè normatif et puis en aval par le
toil étage régulier des normes
excessivement complexes c'est pourquoi
le groupe de travail sur la
simplification des normes dans le cadre
de la délégation au collectivité a
entamé une tâche aride difficile même
frustrante mais au combien nécessaire la
simplification du stock de normes
applicable aux collectivités locales
parce que comme ça a été dit à l'instant
le législateur n'est ni l'unique ni le
principal responsable de l'inflation
normative cette mission simplification
s'est concentré aussi sur la matière
réglementaire et sur les 400000 normes
applicables aux collectivités
territorial en effet on dénombre je vais
pas dire enfin que 8000 lois c'est
beaucoup mais c'est que 8000 lois sur
400000 normes la plupart de nos
partenaires européens ont pris la mesure
de l'inflation réglementaire et de la
nécessité d'y mettre un terme ainsi des
dispositifs innovants ont été
expérimentés par eux au Royaume-Uni le
principe pour une norme créée une norme
supprimée impose au gouvernement de
compenser la création d'une norme
applicable aux entreprises par la
suppression d'une autre et maintenant de
deux autres en Italie le mécanisme dit
de la guillotine réglementaire fixe une
échéance au-delà de laquelle une norme
est présumé supprimée sauf à ce que
l'administration la justifie au demarque
enfin les prescripteurs de normes se
déplacent auprès des acteurs de terrain
pour évaluer avec eux les effets de la
réglementation et les possibilités de
simplification ainsi ces dispositifs ont
permis à ces pays d'atteindre des
résultats significatifs pour ne prendre
qu'un seul exemple la char la charge
administrative a diminué de 25 % au
Danemark selon l'OCDE ainsi la France
doit à son tour intensifier son action
en faveur de la simplification
réglementaire afin de restaurer les
marges d'action des acteurs locaux et et
favoriser l'esprit d'initiative dans nos
territoires et c'est à la simplification
de la réglementation applicable en
matière d'urbanisme et de construction
que le groupe de travail s'est attelé de
nombreux rapports ont depuis longtemps
dénoncé l'anarchie normative qui règne
dans ces domaines et l'urbanisme est
considéré comme un champ de
simplification prioritaire par les élus
par Éric Doliger dans son rapport sur la
simplification des normes en 2011 et
comme un foyer de blocage ou de lenteur
par Alain Lambert et Jean-Claude Boulard
dans leur rapport sur la lutte contre
l'inflation normative de
2013 la complexité des règles
d'urmanisme est également soulignée par
les élus locaux eux-mêmes et je ne
reviendrai pas sur la consultation
conduite de la délégation dont les
résultats ont été rappelés par le
président Jean-Marie Boquel tout à
l'heure 2 ti3 des élus souhaitent que le
droit de l'urbanisme soit allégé pour y
parvenir le groupe de travail a adopté
une méthode innovante associant les élus
et c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
réuni les élus maires de mon département
dont les observations ont nourrit nos
travaux nos élus ont rappelé à cette
occasion la nécessité de mettre fin à la
complexité des dossiers d'urbanisme à
l'enchevêtrement des documents
d'urbanisme aux difficultés
d'application de certaines normes
d'accessibilité de sécurité et de
protection du patrimoine au retard
induit par les études préalables pour
les opérations d'aménagement et au
problèmes de la mise aux normes
européennes des équipements
d'assaainissement collectif et afin de
remédier à ces difficultés le groupe de
travail a souhaité donner une traduction
concrète à certaines préconisations
formulées par les rapports précités à
titre d'illustration il a semblé
opportun de faire suite aux propositions
formulées par Éric d'liger s'agissant
notamment de la création des zones
d'aménagement concerté dans le même
ordre d'idée il a semblé pertinent
d'appuyer une recommandation faite par
Alain Lambert et Jean-Claude Boulard
quant à la nécessité d'ajuster la
réglementation parasismique dans les
zones présentant un très faible risque
constatant le caractère excessif de
cette réglementation ils ont attribué
dans leur rapport le troisième prix des
normes absurdes aux normes parasismique
là où la terre n'a jamais tremblé ce qui
a conduit le Conseil le cnen à
s'autosaisir de cette question être à
l'écoute des élus locaux et faire
aboutir les préconisations des
spécialistes de la simplification
normative voilà en somme le double
esprit qui a présidé à l'élaboration de
cette proposition de résolution ce n'est
pas de la démagogie monsieur Bosino
c'est une réalité je souhaite que le
Sénat en l'adoptant envoie au
gouvernement un signal fort pour
l'encourager à simplifier la
réglementation des domaines de
l'urbanisme et de la construction des
annonces ont été faites dans cette
direction à l'issue du comité inter
ministériel aux ruralités de vezoule le
gouvernement s'est notamment engagé à
harmoniser les niveau d'exigence des
commissions de sécurité et des officiers
préventionnistes à alléger certaines
certains contrôles dans les plus petits
établissements recevant du public et à
simplifier les normes parasismiques dans
les zones de sismicité faiblebl et
modéré donc voilà ces engagements
doivent être pleinement appliqués de
manière à ce que les élus locaux
disposant enfin du cadre juridique
protecteur qu'ils sont en droit
d'attendre je vous remercie de votre
attention et merci monsieur ministre de
veiller à cette
résolution merci mon cher collègue la
parole est à Madame Françoise
gâel vous avez la parole ma cher
collègue pour 8
minutes monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission mes chers collègues
rappelons-le en préambule la norme est
un outil et non une fin en soit
souvenons-nous de ces vérités simples
comme celle de Portalis qui disait que
les lois sont faites pour les hommes et
non les hommes pour les lois certes mon
cher collègue des règles sont
indispensables pour assurer la sécurité
et réguler la vie en société mais force
de constater que leur accumulation finit
par en détraquer le bon fonctionnement
notre pays a besoin de pouvoir agir avec
souplesse
réactivité inventivité tandis que
l'accumulation des règles par
ralenti et ttanisse toute initiative au
dernier classement du Forum économique
mondial la France occupait la 121e place
sur 148 pour le poids des contraintes
administratives l'OCDE estime quant à
elle que notre frénésie réglementaire
aura un coût annuel de 80 milliards
d'euros aujourd'hui 400000 normes
réglementaire s'impose aux seuls
collectivités locales en 4 ans de 201 à
2015 le coût induit par les normes
nouvelles a été évalué à plus d'un
milliard
d'euros ce que Messieurs Lambert et
Boulard appelleent l'incontinence
normative dans leur excellent rapport de
2013 est un obstacle considérable à
l'initiative et surtout à l'efficacité
de l'action publique à forceori le
président de la délégation le rappeler
dans un contexte de crise économique et
de baisse de ressources de nos Collectiv
les normes deviennent un véritable
casse-tête pour les élus et surtout ce
qui est inadmissible un empêchement de
faire face à ce constat la
simplification des normes et la
jugulation d'un flux toujours plus
important sont
primordiales aussi à juste titre le
président du Sénat Gérard Larcher a fait
de la simplification des normes une des
priorités de notre institution qui
depuis plusieurs années a pleinement
pris la mesure de ce problème il
convient de saluer l'excellent travail
de nos collègues Éric Doliger Jacqueline
gourau et Monsieur suur à l'initiative
de la loi de 2013 portant création du
Conseil d'évaluation des normes si les
pouvoirs de ce conseil d'évaluation ont
été élargis les césines en urgence ou en
extrême urgence sont utilisé à outrance
empêchant les élus membres de ce conseil
de mener correctement leur travail de
fond sur ces normes le Conseil national
ne peut à lui seul réaliser l'évaluation
de la totalité des normes il a ainsi
préconisé une procédure de
déclassification des normes existantes
réalisé non seulement par le législateur
mais aussi par les administrations un de
nos brillants collègues le rappelé tout
à l'heure de même le Conseil national
d'évaluation des normes recommande à
juste titre de limiter la sur la
surtransposition des directives
européennes préconisation qui devrait
devenir pour mes chers collègues un
principe obligatoire on le sait les
normes représentent un coût financier
considérable la circulaire de juillet
2013 instaurant la règle d'une norme
nouvelle pour une norme supprimée a été
éditée suite au choc de simplification
voulu par le président or en 2014 303
projets ont été examinés par l'instance
d'évaluation des normes avoisinant un
coût d'1 milliard 4 d'euros en est
pleine cette tendance illustre le fait
que le choc de simplification peine pour
le moment à se traduire dans les faits
en octobre 2014 le Premier ministre et
on salue sa volonté a enjoint les
ministères à compenser toute charge
financière nouvelle liée à une norme par
un allègement équivalent et nous
attendons avec impatience au moment des
vœ de cette nouvelle année ses résultats
l'enquête réalisée par la délégation
collectivité th auprès des maires est en
ce sens très significatif sur 4200
réponses 61 % des élus considèrent la
simplification des normes sur
l'urbanisme comme prioritaire et élus
locaux que nous sommes nous avons tous
vécu des moments de très grande solitude
et de profond désaris dans des
situations confinant à l'absurde face à
une minist à une administration qui
conjugue trop souvent
inlassablement l'empêchement de faire
avec je comprend bien votre question
madame le Maire ou Monsieur le Maire
mais ce que vous demandez n'est pas
possible à cause des règles
d'accessibilité qui ne sont elles-mêmes
pas forcément compatibles avec les
règles de sécurité ou le plus citons
quelques exemples les normes de
construction parasismique concerne 21000
communes contre 5000 auparavant nos
collègues remémy poter l'a rappelé
Lambert et Boulard ont en 2013 attribué
le trè prix des normes absurdes aux
normes smque là où la terre n'a jamais
tremblé l'empilement des documents
d'urbaniste le SCOD le PLU le PLH le
plan de déplacement le Plan climat
énergie ou encore la nécessité de
réaliser parfois trois études distinctes
avant d'entreprendre des travaux en zone
humide l'excès ubuesque de surprécaution
et je l'ai vécu qui conduit parfois des
commissions de sécurité à exigé un
contrôle de la vie du contrôleur
l'incompatibilité de la norme et des
usages comme par exemple celle de la
sécurité de l'incendie dans des crèche
ou des unités d'Alzheimer où il faut
s'assurer de l'impossibilité de sortie
alors même qu'il est nécessaire de
disposer d'issu de secours ouvrable à
tout moment l'étonnante réglementation
sur l'implantation des classes mobiles
fréquente dans nos communes à ce sujet
notre collègue Éric d'ligligier a à
juste titre suggérer que l'autorisation
d'implantation de classe mobile soit
faisable pour la durée d'un chantier et
non renouvelable chaque année
l'insupportable complexité des
procédures de actes le délai actuel de 3
à 5 ans alors qu'on nous presse de
produire des logement détourne les
maires de cet outil extrêmement
pertinent d'aménagement qui oblige à
avoir une vraie vision du développement
de notre commune appuyé sur une démarche
de concertation là encore mes chers
collègues l'excès est l'ennemi du bien
et oseraiis-je parler de situations
invraisemblable issu de l'évolution de
texte de loi et de réglementation et
bien oui je vais le faire en prenant
l'exemple très révélateur d'une commune
de mon département entre le lancement de
la procédure de révision de son plus et
la date définitive d'approbation de
celui-ci le contexte réglementaire a
bougé trois fois pour finalement revenir
à la situation initiale cette commune
avait achevé l'enquête publique sur la
révision de son PL pas de chance
au moment de la promulgation de la loi
allure qui était d'application immédiate
la commune a donc dû relancer la
révision de samplu réaliser une étude
supplémentaire pour intégrer les
nouvelles dispositions et surtout
répondre aux grands étonnements des
habitants qui ne comprenaient pas
pourquoi le maire recommençait un
travail qu' n'avait pas achevé et puis à
peine 6 mois après la loi sur l'avenir
de l'agriculture apportter son lot de
modification et de nouveautés sur le
sujet et en enfin la loi Macron a
assoupli ses dispositions pour que peu
ou prou on revienne aux dispositions
applicable avant l'adoption de la loi
àure mes chers collègues nous marchons
sur la tête il nous faut cesser de
constater avec désespérance cette
incontinence normative et disons-le le
législateur que nous sommes est
responsable de cette surréglementation
comme l'a aussi l'administration dans
les normes qu'elle édicte c'est pour ça
que je salue l'excellente initiative de
la délégation collectivité territoriale
et de son président et l'excellent
travail de notre collègue reméy po dont
je connaît la détermination il nous faut
agir vraiment cesser de dire pour que
nous puissions enfin cesser de gémir
simplifier ne veut pas dire
dérèglementer simplifier doit être pour
nous par contre une ardente obligation
car la loi a pour objet de permettre
d'agir et de résoudre des questions et
non d'empêcher de faire car empêcher de
faire n'a jamais supprimé une un
problème comme vous le déduisez comme
l'invite à le dire monsieur le Président
le groupe udiuc votera cette excellente
proposition je vous remercie merci ma
cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur René
virongsur
présentur président monsieur le
ministre soyons d'abord beau
joueur la proposition de révision de la
loi constitutionnelle a été approuvée
nous sommes donc cher remmi po je suis
sûr que vous n'avez aucun doute dans
votre esprit à quelques semaines du vote
en terme identique par l'Assemblée
nationale et de l'organisation de du
référendum nécessaire à l'entrée en
vigueur de cet important
texte ça m'empêchera pas tout en
m'inclinant devant l'importance de la
procédure
à porter un jugement plus que positif
sur la proposition de résolution
pourquoi parce que j'avais eu la chance
ça a été dit par d'autres de mes
collègues de
travailler avec le rapporteur Alain
Richard Alain Lambert madame gourau
monsieur suur sur le
renforcement de la nem et je
mesure fort de la mission qu'a donné à
Jean-Marie Boquel et à la délégation le
président du Sénat je mesure l'ampleur
et le caractère ingraas vous avez eu
raison de le souligner de la tâche qui
est ici et et je trouve que si les
choses bougent parce que moi je vais
soutenir qu'elle bouge hein vous y êtes
la
délégation le Sénat il est
incontestablement pour beaucoup je ne
reviens pas parce que j'ai le respect
d'éviter les redites sur les
observations de la Cour des comptes qui
sont loin d'être neutres sur ce qui
manque
d'articulation entre le secrétariat
général du gouvernement et la CNEM pour
arriver à donner aux
procédures dont on le ministre a dit que
la saisine avait été considérablement
allégée je voudrais juste revenir
sur l'interprétation facilitatrice
c'est-à-dire la thèse défendue hier
monsieur mard par le secrétaire d'État
monsieur
valini en disant sénatrice sénateur il y
a quelque chose qui est en train de
changer en France vous ne l'avez
peut-être pas encore totalement perçu
c'est que quand les circulaires arrivent
au préfet ça n'est plus pour leur dire
c'est comme ça et pas autrement que vous
appréciez les textes mais c'est comme le
dit le Conseil d'État une circulaire
interprétative du droit souple dit le
Conseil d'État qui laisse au préfet un
pouvoir
d'appréciation monsieur valallini nous
dira tout à l'heure ce qu'il de la ligne
aérienne du Cantal dont il a été
beaucoup question pendant la discussion
de la loi de nôre mais enfin un préfet
d' nom devrait savoir l'interpréter de
la manière suivante à partir du moment
où la région a supposé qu'elle le fasse
ne reprend pas cette compétence au nom
de la solidarité territoriale au nom de
la solidarité territorial je vois pas ce
qui empêcherait le département de le
faire et ça nous amène cet exemple
concret que je savais pas que vous en
parleriez aujourd'hui mais c'est un
excellent exemple ça nous amène à saluer
un certain nombre d'avancé dans le la
matière de l'urbanisme je vais pas
rallonger mon propos mais je voudrais
quand même parce que biscuit avalé n'a
plus de
goût salueer quand même les mesures
prises dans la foulée du comité
interministériel de
vezou sur les ruralités hein au pluriel
et et vous mes chers collègues qui
connaissez le territoire c'est la
première fois que vous avez
effectivement de l'ordre qui est remis
dans les la réglementation sur les
pluses c'est c'est la première fois que
vous avez également des dispositions et
je je connais
parfaite bien sûr mais c'est la première
fois que vous avez un plus qui devient
assujetti au projet du maire ou des élus
et non plus un urbanisme réglementaire
qui est un carcan qui les empêche de
mettre en œuvre le projet alors je
voudrais saluer ça comme je salue aussi
les progrès du côté du Conseil
d'État le progrès du côté du Conseil
d'État à l'initiative de Cécile Dufflot
ça aussi on l'a oublié et oui et oui oui
qui a permis qui a permis justement de
lutter contre les recours dilatoires en
matière de de permis de construire et
cela grâce notamment au préconisations
de la commission
labetoule ceci étant moi ce sur quoi je
voudrais le plus insister puisque quand
on parle de ces questions là on parle
toujours de la
question du droit à l'expérimentation
version
ou version de Rémi point TR de la
possibilité de
différenciation alors je voudrais dire
qu'ici et je
salue Jean-Jacques yest ici dans la loi
nôtre en défendant Le Strat le schéma
régional d'aménagement du territoire
nous avons tenu à ce que cet outil qui a
une por juridique c'est une des grands
changements puiss justement à l'échelle
régionale constitué en matière
d'aménagement du territoire une prise en
compte des fac des spécificités du
territoire de ces enjeux économiques
sociaux environnementaux afin
précisément j'ai pas peur du mot de
savoir adapter la règle he je rappelle
le droit souple c'est pas nous qui
l'avons inventé c'est le Conseil d'État
qui nous a rappeler à bon droit que s'il
est pas si souple que ça on n'y est pas
nous pour rien il y a certes
l'administration mais il y a aussi le
rôle du législateur alors
osons cette différenciation dans
l'application vous avez dit monsieur le
ministre que les CTAP vont déjà
permettre cette adaptation au territoire
des politiques publiques moi je plaide
pour la simplification vous voyez moi je
vais jusqu'à dire des scottes des
scottes il couvre même pas 20 % du
territoire national et ben on peut s'en
passer on peut très bien fonctionner
avec des schémas régionaux d'aménagement
du territoire engage l'essentiel à la
bonne échelle qui plus est quand vous
êtes sur les problématiques d'talement
urbain de préservation des terres
agricoles d'assaainissement d'hydrologie
de de lutte contre un certain nombre de
pollution vous êtes à la bonne échelle
vous n'avez pas besoin de ce si vous
saviez le nombre de temps quand en
région nordpatcalé les élus passent dans
un exercice qu'ils appellent
l'interscotte concl mon cher collègue à
essayer de se coordonner vous vous
rendriez compte que l'heure est venue de
simplifier et je conclus par là
continuons à simplifier
merci la parole est à Monsieur André
Vallini secrétaire d'État chargé de la
réforme
territoriale Vous AVEZ LA PAROLE
monsieur le ministre
merci merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs nous sommes donc réunis cet
après-midi comme hier après-midi à peu
près à la même heure autour du sujet
relatif aux normes excessives
contraignant coûteuse qui pèse sur nos
collectivités
locales et plus précisément nous
débattons vous débattez et je vais
intervenir à mon tour à propos d'une
proposition de résolution qui vise à
simplifier et alléger des normes
applicables au collectivité
territoriales résolution qui émane de la
délégation sénatoriale aux collectivité
local que préside Jean-Marie Boquel et
que et dont le vice-président chargé de
la lutte contre les normes et le
sénateur remémi
pointer les éléments de ce débat sont
connus nous avons eu l'occasion je le
répète d'en parler beaucoup hier nous en
parlons souvent depuis longtemps
notamment dans cet hémicycle et dans nos
départements
respectifs et je veux commencer mon
propos comme je l'ai fait hier en vous
disant et vous le savez et les sénateurs
Bosino l'abbé la sénatrice bataille
l'ont l'ont fort à propos rappel en
disant que la norme elle est utile elle
est même souvent indispensable
elle est nécessaire dans un état de
droit d'abord et dans une société qui se
veut
développer je pense au domaine de la
santé
au domaine de l'environnement ou au
domaine qu'évoqué hier Jean-Pierre Vial
au domaine de l'accessibilité des
bâtiments publics notamment au
handicapés grâce à des normes parfois
contraignantes et elles sont là pour ça
des progrès considérables ont été
accomplis depuis quelques années en
matière de protection de l'environnement
de santé publique et je le répète en
faveur des handicapés donc premier
élément il ne faut
pas boliser totalement et complètement
la nécessité dans nos sociétés d'avoir
des normes parfois contraignantes et
c'est vrai parfois un peu coûteuse aussi
deuxè
élément je reprendrai ce qu'a dit hier
le sénateur Vial toujours lui mais aussi
je crois le sénateur
bookel à l'origine de la prolifération
des normes qui
a-t-il le
Parlement et les gouvernements successif
de droite comme de gauche qui vous
propose comme il propose au députés de
plus en plus de lois et des lois de plus
en plus longues et ce constat il a été
dressé depuis longtemps par le Conseil
d'État par le Conseil constitutionnel
par Jean-Louis Debray notamment mais pas
seulement donc que ce débat comme hier
après-midi au-delà des clivages
partisans nous permette aussi de faire
notre examen de conscience le mot est un
peu fort mais sachons reconnaître les
responsabilités des et des autres dans
ce problème qui est réel et j'en vient
maintenant aux solutions parce que tout
problème a une solution et le problème
parce qu'il y a problème que pose la
prolifération normative a des
solutions monsieur le Président mard
vous êtes président d'une agglomération
au ryac où j'étais l'autre jour et où on
m'a parlé de l'aéroport effectivement et
vous avez à nommé des délégués des
représentants dans de nombreuses
commissions notamment celles qui
s'occupent des chauve-souris j'ai été
président du conseil général de liser et
j'avais moi-même à nommer à déléguer des
représentants peut-être monsieur Savin
d'ailleurs dans tel ou tel commission
qui s'occupait elles aussi des
chauves-souris et d'autres animaux
dignes évidemment de de
notre
sollicitude donc je connais ces ces
sujets et le sénateur Savin se
souviendra peut-être des années des
années que j'ai dû patienter pour
obtenir la réalisation d'un pont dans
mon mon propre canton entre Tulin et
Saint-Quentin
beaucoupex à cause de la protection
nécessaire en tout cas rendu nécessaire
par une norme de la protection des
tritons
crétés il a fallu surmonter de nombreux
obstacles et le jour où j'ai enfin cru
parvenir au but on m'a expliqué que le
chantier devait devait être retardé
parce que il allait s'ouvrir ce chantier
en pleine période de ation des
hondelles vous vous en souvenez monsieur
le sénateur de liser donc je connais
bien ces sujets qui sont
exaspérant de la même façon monsieur le
sénateur pin que j'ai été maire moi
aussi de ma petite ville natale et que
j'ai eu à respecter la réglementation
qui veut que parce que l'église de
Thulin est classée que dans un périmètre
de 500 m de rayon on puisse pas
construire et tant mieux d'ailleurs
aussi pour la protection du patrimoine
qu'on ne puisse pas construire
exactement ce que l'on veut
avec parfois des excès de la part des
fameuses
ABF donc nous sommes tous d'accord sur
le constat et nous sommes tous d'accord
pour vouloir agir et les gouvernements
successifs là encore ont essayé d'agir
de droite comme de gauche alors j'ai
plutôt t tendance à défendre celui
auquel j'appartiens le gouvernement et
c'est la raison pour laquelle je vais
vous dire que ce gouvernement agit
peut-être pas mieux que les autres mais
en tout cas beaucoup plus que ça n'a été
le cas depuis une quinzaine d'années
sous comment dire à
l'instigation sous la pression au bon
sens du terme notamment du Sénat des
sénateurs de la délégation sénatoriale
présidé par Jean-Marie Boquel cette
action s'inscrit dans le choc de
simplification voulu par le Président de
la République comme l'a rappelé la
sénatrice Gatel le gouvernement a engagé
une action résolue et pour cela le
gouvernement s'appuie sur le cnen
Conseil national d'évaluation des les
présidé par votre ancien collègue Alain
Lambert ASI que sur deux circulaires
l'une du 17 juillet 2013 et l'autre du 9
octobre
2014 un premier bilan peut-être tiré de
comment dire la nouvelle impulsion qui a
donné le gouvernement depuis 2013 à
cette lutte contre les normes d'abord un
bilan sur le flux je sais que les
chiffres sont toujours sujets à
contestation notamment dans ce domaine
donc je ne citerai pas de chiffres je
veux simplement vous dire que la DGCL
qui ass sur le secrétariat du CN formel
l'objectif de zéro charge nouvelle en
2015 a été
tenu chaque fois qu'une norme nouvelle a
été créée
ou que l'aggravation entre guillemets
d'une norme existante a été décidée l'
l'administration a été tenu d'obtenir un
allègement d'un montant équivalent d'une
norme existante donc la tendance elle
est claire le résultat il est net il
faut bien sûr ne pas s'en satisfaire il
faut aller plus loin et pour
accentuer encore cette tendance
favorable que personne ne conteste au
cnen pour l'accentuer en 2016 nous
allons à la demande d'an Lambert
notamment améliorer l'évaluation des
conséquences financières des textes qui
sont présentés au CN parce que ces
évaluations ne sont pas suffisamment
détaillées et je disais hier à cette
tribune que les administrations
centrales se contente encore trop
souvent en guise de concertation avec
les associations d'élus d'une note
d'information ou d'un
email la concertation parfois se résume
encore à ça de la part des
administrations centrales en direction
des associations d'élu ça doit changer
et des directives ont été données en ce
sens une circulaire a été envoyée par le
Premier ministre le 12 octobre dernier à
tous les membres du gouvernement pour
leur rappeler que les évaluations
financières qui émanent de leurs
administrations doivent être aussi
précises que possible ce qui n'est pas
le cas aujourd'hui j'en viens au stock
après le flux le stock lui aussi fait ob
de toute notre
attention une mission d'inspection
jeeliè a été mandatée en 2014 pour faire
en 2015 pardon pour faire ressortir les
normes les plus contestables et discuter
de leur bien fondés à l'issue de ce
rapport de la mission d'inspection 76
propositions regroupé par thématique
dans l'urbanisme qui vous occupe cet
après-midi ont été formulés j'ajoute à
ce travail qui a été initié par la
mission d'inspection et que nous suivons
maintenant de près j'ajoute que j'ai
réuni à 6 reprises des ateliers
thématiques à mon
cabinet avec des associations d'élus à
qui j'avais demander de nous fournir si
j'ose dire de nous envoyer à ces
réunions des praticiens de la norme
c'est-à-dire des DGS des directeurs
généraux des services vous le savez et
des DST des directeurs de services
techniqu des praticiens au quotidien de
la norme les élus sont évidemment très
compétents et ont raison de de vouloir
dénoncer la tion des Nmes mais ceux qui
les vivent au jour le jour qui sont là
pour les appliquer avec difficulté ce
sont les DGS et les DST à la suite de C
six ateliers thématiques une dizaine de
propositions a été formulé après chaque
réunion et de série de simplification
ont été acté ces derniers mois d'abord
cela a été dit tout à l'heure par le
sénateur Viren donc la loi notre a
intégré 16 mesures de simplification
dont 12 étaient issu du rapport du
sénateur de
à qui je rendais hommage hier après-midi
et je le fais à nouveau volontiers cet
après-midi donc 16 mesures de
simplification j'ai ici le détail vous
le connaissez la loi a été longuement
débatue ici et cela a été dit aussi par
le sénateur Vandy rend donc et la
sénatrice bataille le 14 septembre
dernier lors du comité interministériel
au ruralité qui s'est tenu à vezou 18
mesures de simplification de normes
existantes ont été
annoncées notamment le domaine des
bâtiments publque de l'urbanisme et
d'autres encore alors pour aller plus
loin en 2016 toujours sur le stock deux
évolutions importantes ont été décidé
par le Premier ministre la première
concerne le renforcement de notre
dispositif nous avons donc
obtenu qu'une équipe du sgmap le
secrétariat général à la modernisation
de l'action publique soit dédié au suivi
de l'allègement des normes il y a
maintenant des fonctionnaires et il en
faut bien sûr y compris pour simplifier
qui sont chargés de suivre les
allègements décidés les simplifications
décidé parce que une chose est de dire
qu'on va simplifier une norme de l'acter
dans un comité interministériel ou même
dans une loi comme la loi nôre une autre
chose et de suivre l'allègement et la
simplification et que tout ça ne se
perde pas dans les sables de
l'administration centrale donc nous
avons obtenu un renforcement de notre
équipe de suivi grâce à
euh le grâce au SG map qui nous a dédié
une équipe pour cela la deuxième
évolution qui est importante et qui a
été demandée à l'époque par Jean-Marie
Boquel et Rémy pointerau lors d'une
proposition de loi qu'ils avaient déposé
le 20 mai dernier je vous avais expliqué
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs que
cette proposition de loi ne convenait
pas parce que elle visait à modifier un
décret et j'avais pris l'engagement
devant vous que j'obtiendrai la
modification de ce décret cela a pris du
temps j'en conviens beaucoup de temps
pas une semaine ne s'est passé sans que
je m'inquiète de savoir où on était ce
fameux décret il est resté longtemps
dans certains bureaux ensuite il est
resté très longtemps au Conseil d'État
et enfin la semaine
dernière nous avons obtenu la
publication de ce décret qui permet
maintenant à chaque maire pris isolément
de saisir le cnen avant ce décret il
fallait que sans maire se réunissent
c'est beaucoup de réunir sans mare même
s'il y en a 36000 pardon
35945 euh depuis quelques quelques jours
sans maire sur le même sujet précis ça
n'est pas si évident que ça donc
aujourd'hui désormais un maire peut
saisir directement le
cnen d'une modification d'un allègement
voir même d'une suppression de normes
qu'il
souhaite j'en viens au trème point je
l'ai fait hier après-midi déjà vous
savez qu'il y a le flux bien sûr qui est
trop important le stock qui est très
important il y a aussi et j'allais dire
peut-être surtout les conditions
d'application des normes les élus locaux
quand on les interroge se plaainent bien
sûr de l'excès de normees se plaainent
surtout de la difficulté qu'ils ont à
appliquer les normes du manque de
conseil de l'interprétation qui est
faite parfois par
l'administration donc c'est le troisème
chantier auquel le Premier ministre m'a
demandé de m'attaquer et sur un conseil
judicieux du sénateur Boulard expert en
la
matière j'ai suggéré au Premier ministre
il y a quelques semaines d'adresser une
circulaire au préfet et à tous les chefs
de service déconcentrés de l'État pour
leur prescrire une interprétation
facilitatrice des normes ou comme
diraient les
Québécois un accommodement raisonnable
je trouve la formule plus usagée plus
plus imagée encore un accommodement
raisonnable dans l'application de la
norme selon les réalités du terrain
selon les réalités de la collectivité
locale à laquelle on doit appliquer
cette norme cette
circulaire le Premier ministre a été
d'accord pour la
signé et elle va être adressée au préfet
dans les prochains jours on m'avait dit
en décembre on est en janvier donc je
vais à nouveau m'inquiéter de savoir si
les préfets vont bientôt la recevoir
vous pourrez d'ailleurs et je vous
invite instamment à le faire je le
disais hier après-midi ici même lors de
des cérémonies de vœux auquel nous
participons tous dans nos cantons dans
nos
départements il y a beaucoup d'élus
locaux faites savoir aux élus locaux que
non seulement ils peuvent maintenant
saisir le cnen par votre intermédiaire
pourquoi pas et puis aussi qu'ils
peuvent qu'ils pourront en tout cas
bientôt dire au préfet mais vous avez
reçu une circulaire du Premier ministre
qui vous demande d'interpréter de façon
facilitatrice telle ou telle norme cette
circulaire il faudra la faire connaître
aux
élus
alors j'en viens maintenant et plus
précisément à votre proposition de
résolution qui invite en premier lieu le
gouvernement à remplacer la circulaire
du 17 juillet
2013 relative à la mise en œuvre du gel
de la réglementation par un
décret je ne suis pas certain que le
fait de remonter dans la hiérarchie des
normes ce principe de compensation
permettent très efficacement et très
rapidement de maîtriser l'inflation norm
ce qui compte en la matière vous le
savez
bien c'est d'abord la volonté la volonté
politique et cette volonté politique
vous l'avez ici au Sénat et nous l'avons
au gouvernement et cette volonté elle
doit s'appliquer aussi à changé la
culture de l'administration française en
France trop souvent encore nos
fonctionnaires nos hauts fonctionnaires
considèrent qu'agir c'est édictter
qu'agir c'est réglementer qu'agir c'est
forcément
légiférer aujourd'hui nous devons faire
comprendre à l'administration qu'agir ça
peut-être aussi
inciter plutôt que réglementer que ça
conseiller plutôt que de légiférer ou de
réglementer hier j'ai
évoqué une autre idée du sénateur
Boulard que partage d'ailleurs al
Lambert ils ont fait un travail
remarquable
dans ce domaine l'idée d'un guide des
bonnes pratiques d'un référentiel de
bonnes pratiqu qui pourrait dans de
nombreux domaines se substituer à des
normes trop contraignantes il faut
réfléchir à quelques domaines dans
lesquels on pourrait expérimenter ce
genre de de méthode j'aiévoqué hier le
le sujet des des
cantines vous savez que la
réglementation dans dans ce domaine est
très tatillonne très
précise je crois même me souvenir d'un
conseil des ministres où je présentais
euh un bilan d'étapes sur mon action
contre les normes où j'avais évoqué la
différence de longueur et de diamètre
des quenelles qui sont servies dans les
cantines selon qu'il s'agisse d'enfants
d'écooles maternell d'écoes primair ou
de collège or il y a on sait bien dans
nos département de nombreux restaurants
scolaires où mangent à la fois des
enfants de la maternelle plus souvent du
primaire et du collège et c'est un
cass-etê pour le l'intendant qui est
chargé de de de gérer ce restaurant
scolaire donc il faut faire confiance
d'abord au bon sens des fonctionnaires
notamment les fonctionnaires qui sont au
plus près de la réalité vécu par nos
concitoyens et puis il faut dans ce
domaine par exemple plutôt aller vers un
référenciel de bonne pratique que vers
une norme tatillonne et quasiment
impossible à appliquer et il y en a
beaucoup donc je vous soumets cette
cette idée et ce sujet il peut y en
avoir
d'autres autre évolution à laquelle nous
avons réfléchi hier notamment avec le
sénateur Jean-Pierre Vial et l'ensemble
de
l'hémicycle celle d'une administration
différenciée de nos territoires je vous
ai écouté attentivement les uns et les
autres et vous avez tous plus ou moins
dit que il faut adapter la norme les
normes à la réalité locale à nos
réalités locales c'est déjà possible et
ça sera plus encore demain grâce à la
Loire car vous le savez dans cette loi
il est prévu c'est à l'article 1er que
les régions pourront formuler des
propositions d'évolution des lois et
règlements en vigueur ou en cours
d'élaboration dans leur domaine de
compétence alors ce pouvoir
d'adaptation que vont avoir les régions
qu' les régions depuis le début de ce
mois respectera le principe d'égalité
d'égalité républicaine à laquelle nous
sommes tous très attachés si deux
conditions sont remplies la première
c'est c'est que la modulation locale
dans l'application d'une norme
législative devra reposer sur une
différence objective de situation entre
les territoires ou entre les
collectivités ou sur une raison
d'intérêt général la deuxième condition
qu'il faudra remplir c'est que la
différence de traitement devra être en
rapport direct avec les finalités de la
législation dans le cadre de laquelle le
législateur décide de confier au
collectivité locale un pouvoir
réglementaire sous ces deux réserves en
respectant ces deux critères les régions
pourront
adapter la
législation qui s'applique à l'ensemble
du pays selon les réalités de de leur
territoire enfin et cela a été dit par
le sénateur Viren donc on n'a pas assez
mesuré on le fera au fil des mois et des
années qui viennent le rôle facilitateur
que vont avoir les CTAP dans
l'organisation adaptée de
l'administration des administrations
locales aux réalités de nos territoires
puisque les CTAP pour ont dans chaque
région les conférences territoriales de
l'action publique décider que telle ou
telle compétence peut-être déléguée ici
à tel département ici à telle communauté
d'agglomération ou esttelle communauté
de
commune voilà ce que je voulais dire sur
le premier point de votre résolution le
deuxè point concerne plusieurs mesures
de simplification que vous proposez nous
y avons beaucoup travailler avec les
services de l'administration et mon
le gouvernement est très intéressé par
ces propositions certaines d'ailleurs
ont été engagées dès le comité
interministériel de vezou le 14
septembre dernier je pense notamment la
proposition d'établir une charte
nationale en concertation avec les élux
locaux pour harmoniser les niveaux
d'exence en matière de sécurité et de
prévention de même que vous proposez
d'alléger ou de supprimer les normes
parasismiques alors là c'est un sujet
que connaî parfaitement comme d'autres
sujets le sénateur Boulard il m'en a
saisi j'ai commencé à faire bouger les
choses ce n'est pas facile je sais qu'il
y a
des territoir dans notre pays où la
terre n'a jamais tremblé et où la
géologie indique qu'elle ne devrait pas
trembler avant longtemps et où pourtant
les normes parasismiques s'imposent
induisant un coût supplémentaire dans la
construction des
bâtiments donc je je je m'en préoccupe
aussi presque chaque semaine en tout cas
mon cabinet est là pour ça et voilà je
suis en
négociation je suis en négociation avec
le ministère de l'Environnement monsieur
sénateur et ça n'est pas facile et si
j'osais cette
formule le ministère de l'Environnement
ses sa façon de voir les
choses dans beaucoup de domaines dans
beaucoup de domaines et si j'osais la
formule un peu facile je dirais comme
c'est compliqué de simplifier dans notre
pays vous proposer de simplifier la
réglementation applicable au plan locaux
d'urbanisme ça a été annoncé aussi lors
du comité interministériel de de vezou
d'autres propositions comme l'exclusion
du contrôle de l'égalité d'actes de
faible importance l'ajustement de la
périodicité du contrôle des
installations électrique ont également
été engagé lors du comité
interministériel de vezou j'ai ici une
liste je vous l'avais promise hier mais
je je ne vais pas vous en donner lecture
de toutes les mesures de simplification
d'allègement qui sont en cours d'examen
ou de réalisation euh c'est c'est du
concret ça ne mérite pas d'être
mentionné in extino à la tribune mais la
mesure numéro neuf par exemple concerne
l'harmonisation des dispositions
concurrentes je dis bien concurrentes
concernant l'inclinaison de la pente des
bordures de piscine parce qu'il y a
plusieurs mais oui mais on en est là oui
et mon travail consiste pour ça qu' faut
changer les choses et c'est un travail
de bénédictin
ou de Romain selon la période que l'on
préfère mon travail consiste à ça à
descendre dans le détail des choses pour
que les mesures concernant l'inclinaison
des pantes de piscine soient harmonisées
parce que les réglementations ne sont
pas les mêmes selon l'administration
concernée de la même façon que
l'obligation de vidange des bassins de
piscine je reste sur les piscines va
être ramené à une par an au lieu de deux
ce qui représente quand même une
économie importante pour une commune de
faible importance qui a la chance
d'avoir une piscine car une vidange de
piscine ça coûte cher tout ça paraît un
peu loin aux administrations centrales
et au aux fonctionnaires qui sont
excellent que le monde entier nous envit
et que je rencontre régulièrement mais
c'est du concret c'est du vécu par les
élus et je vais chaque semaine dans un
département vous le savez et notamment
les départements les plus éloignés des
agglomérations urbaines ceux qui se
sentent un peu en tout cas c'est ce
qu'ils disent délaissé par Paris ce
n'est pas le cas mais je vais leur dire
justement que ce n'est pas le cas et que
je vais dans ces départements pour
écouter les élus et souvent on me parle
de choses aussi concrète que ça je serai
demain en Vendé pour 2 jours je serai la
semaine prochaine à nouveau en
lozer et je montre par là aux élus que
le gouvernement se préoccupe de leur vie
quotidienne et mon travail il est là il
est d'abord là dans le suivi des mesures
les plus plus concrètes les plus
pragmatiques qui vous intéressent en
tant que représentant constitutionnel
des collectivités locales alors en
conclusion Mesdames et Messieurs les
sénateur le gouvernement va si la
résolution est adoptée je pense qu'elle
le sera étudié très attentivement
chacune des propositions qui sont faites
et puisque nous partageons le même
objectif j'allais dire la même
philosophie dans ce domaine le
gouvernement sur le vote de la
résolution s'en remettra à la sagesse de
votre assemblée je vous remercie merci
monsieur le ministre
nous allons procéder au vote sur la
proposition de
résolution la Conférence des Présidents
a décidé que les interventions des
orateurs valent explication de vote je
mets don au voix la proposition de
résolution qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient la proposition de
résolution est
adopté
annces voilà vous avez donc pu suivre
l'adoption de cette proposition de
résolution
centriste sur la simplification des
normes elle a été adoptée la semaine
dernière par le Sénat et vous pouvez
revoir bien sûr ce programme sur notre
site internet
publsenat.fr